フォレああああ
米山外れ社長です皆さん俺よって動かせご存知でしょうか
有名なんで見たことある人多いと思うんですけどもこちらですね俺を
+がにこれ人気すぎる知らない人いないと思うんですよねこういうですね空気が狂って
中が白いクリームが入っているのが特徴のクリームクッキーなんですけどもまぁどこが
特徴的かというとこういう感じ
分解して食べれるんですよねこのクリームがとっても安心
ですよねいただきます
まあクリームだけ食べたいもう裏でも美味しい食べ方の障害もしてるんですけども俺は
実はですねパーツに名前が付いてまして名前の通り俺様っていうのは夫ねとこなんです
よつまり真ん中にあるこの白いの版でそして外にある黒いやつが夫王なんですそれを
合わせでも良
たぶんそうでつまりこの冗談今居るようなんですけどもつまりこうやってをがあって
知ったの方だけ外すとこれで俺ここにれようがあってここに俺があってこれを
組み合わせると俺よ俺に大つけてここでさらにべをくっつけると俺お礼をというように
ですねこれ俺をのように見えて
をぞレイズ作られてるんでその組み合わせによっていろんな長い
作れるんですよそろそろすごいやってた海外の動画がありましてそれがちょっと画像
だったんですけどまずとする実写でやってみようかなと思いましてとたくさんお礼が
あるんです早速誰か考えた横領の組み合わせをちょっとまずは行ってみようと思います
がご覧ください
その前に1件発送等さんのを取りが1人乗りでね色々外しと糸があ
死んだこいつ
ストレスネットゾーンにあったオレオの組をやってみようと思いますご覧ください
どうぞ
rooro アーレ朧らをレオリオレウれおれオレズレねーよおーれれ0 o 俺
れりゃ o
ああああハ
ran
2期2町でデイリーとかマジで大変だったんですけども急で今回は耐えるようなを
トレーを準備したのでこれを使って今まで誰も作ったことがないような素晴らしいを
取りの組み合わせを作ってみようと思います結構も折れるラオウをて結構疲れたんです
けどもこれを超えるも俺俺俺俺俺を俺レベ様とか
nao
俺を neo ネオレベル法王が俺はロロルル舐められ
ちょっと大変だと思うんですけども組み合わせれば必ず何かできるのが豊漁でちょっと
頑張って作ってみようと思いますではない
[音楽]
ねうん
俺俺でも折れる俺俺おねおね
で10 j 俺俺俺ルール俺でレッドれ
れるで俺で
[音楽]
アイドルである程度僕を作れた絵を透明の首を垂れてきました
あの
めっちゃくちゃ面白かったですね勝手にも口ずさんちゃうんですよねおおぉ
ね俺は俺をご覧すごいつけて楽しかったです後関係者食べ物で遊んでるワケがありませ
ん
芸術ですと言われて結構時間がかかったんですけどもあの僕の自信作のオレオが大私立
ご覧ください
どうぞ
俺俺俺俺俺俺俺俺俺俺俺溺れるレベルで競れれるぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜー
ぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜー
ぜーぜーぜーぜー俺俺出るででオレオレ小倉れるで俺溺れ俺
で0でおれオレをグーッ
ロレ俺俺俺連れで俺を音ずれておらおられろれれれれれれられ
オーラオーラ大連嶺俺レオレオレオ俺俺俺ね俺ぜ俺ぜよ
レゲエで俺俺俺俺を手で俺俺俺で俺を
売れでオレオレで俺を俺はろ love られる
me
あっはぁ
写真撮らないと所持となる遠いとい